hey what's up on today's show we talk
about some hard adult themes so watch
out for the little ears in the room
our first caller is a young man who is
struggling to figure out how to have a
hard hard conversation with his buddy
we talked to a woman who found out that
her husband's got a pornography
addiction dating back
years we talked to a awesome
young woman who is coming out of a hard
broken relationship
and she's wondering how she can trust
herself to find love again
stay tuned
hey what's up good folks it's delony
welcome to the dr john delony show
the show about you your lives the
messiness the cuts and the bruises
and the blood and the scrapes and the
good stuff and the bad
stuff all of it the anxiousness and the
depression
and the madness how we become okay with
what we see in the mirror
here's the thing if you're new to our
band of ninjas welcome along we're so
happy to have you
we are still figuring this out uh we
talk about everything on the show from
mental health challenges to
family and relational iq questions
schooling education
what happened to my kids addiction
infidelity
anything you can imagine i love walking
alongside folks
as we figure it out together i'm still
figuring it out i'm a dad i'm a husband
i'm just a guy in my community trying to
do the best i can to
um to do right by myself and by my
family and by my neighbors and so
we're all figuring out together give me
a call at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
and sometimes on the show we talk about
things that drive me crazy and annoying
things and just a little while ago in
the office
i'll lean my chair back and i said hey
is anybody have anything that drives
them crazy
and that makes them annoyed and so one
awesome young woman she said when people
show up to four-way
stops and they get there before you and
then they just sit there and they just
start waving at you
and she says i get all confused and
nervous and i start to go and then they
go and stop
and she's like if people just follow the
freaking rules
when you get to the four-way stop first
then you just go it doesn't make you
noble just to sit there for an extra 10
seconds and make somebody feel awkward
so that was kind of fun one guy in the
office said
drives me crazy when i finally
save up my willpower for a cheat day
this dude's all ripped and buff he's way
better looking than all of us
when he has a cheat day he goes to the
drive-through to get a large fry
in the stingy suckers in the
drive-through just put like a medium fry
worth of fries in the large fry
dude it's like six cents just fill the
sucker up make me feel good about myself
uh uh um the five guys burgers dude
those guys know what's up they fill that
bag
all the way up it's just a bag of
diabetes and it's so good man they don't
they hook you up
and then one guy named tyler he's like
you know what's annoying deloney
you you are annoying colony to which
rachel who runs all of our calendars she
goes yeah he's kind of right tyler
so there's a few annoying things from
our neighbors here in my office
so give me a call 1-844-693-3291 or go
to johndaloney.com fill out the form
it goes right to kelly and she will
connect you
with this show and so
you know what we got a lot to talk about
today but we're gonna go straight to the
calls let's get into the calls and then
we'll talk as we go so let's go
to charlie in alexandria louisiana
charlie what's up brother how we doing
doing good how are you john
good what's going on man well uh
i've had a bit of a situation kind of
fall into my lap it's not something that
you know i asked for
but uh it's here and i've got to deal
with it concerning a
good friend of mine and i just was
looking for some advice from you about
how i approach him about the situation
and
how our friendship should move on from
where it is now
cool man so go on what happened
well over this uh past summer
i found out from my fiance who found out
from his wife
that he had been soliciting
sexually explicit pictures from uh
many other women other than his wife
some of those including
minors come on why yeah
man me and my fiance we we went to the
police with it
a couple days after we found out hey can
i just stop you right there and say
absolutely i'm grateful for you dude
thank you to you and your fiance for
being people of character and doing hard
things good for you man
that's awesome yeah i'm i'm super
thankful for her she
she really was cut and dry with this
and was like we need to go and shoot
well you're hey you're marrying what we
make friends tough decisions
hang on to her man that's a person a
character that has
zero tolerance for freaking evil people
all right go ahead brother i'm sorry if
i cut you off go ahead ma'am
yo went to i know that was hard it was
uncomfortable and then what happened
uh well since our information is
basically second hand everything we know
came from uh his wife right
there's nothing that's really been done
about i mean they took our statement my
report
uh and what happened but as far as i
know nothing's been
done with it okay uh when did you make
this report
uh this would have been back in
june it would have been back in june
okay
so you made a report in june and here
you are
just a few weeks into the new year
what's your question for me man
so i this is like one of my best friends
i was best man at his wedding
he was supposed to walk in my wedding
and we're just
we haven't addressed it and i don't know
how i
should confront him about this
dude homie you're his best man you
confront this by going and banging on
his front door
and you have been invited and earned the
right to put your finger in his chest
and say dude
what in the world is wrong with you what
are you doing what has happened to your
brain and your spirit um this is what
best men are for
charlie is confrontation
and it's for accountability
that's that's i mean that's why he asked
you to be his best man
right right and so you you have a
responsibility to get
active you did the right thing you
called the police
and that's the legal part of this the
friendship part of it man you are all up
in his business about that
why is that hard for you why does that
make you uncomfortable
i'm i'm not entirely sure
i just i don't want to have to
deal with that conflict that i know
that's going to be there because
hey you're not his friend then man he's
not a friend to you
you're not a friend to him call it and
then move on with your life
if you want to have relationships that
are conflict-free you're never going to
have relationships
that are worth anything i would con i
would deeply
suggest you postpone any sort of
marriage plans you have
because marriage is full of conflict the
best ones have
a lot of conflict because man that's i
mean that's that's what good
deep relationships are all about is
when the good times are good they're
good and when they are rough you ride or
die together and when somebody
violates core values of this is of any
human being man
soliciting pictures of minors from
minors dude god almighty
and again you are right and there's
something to think through you don't
know it could have been his wife
uh made up stuff got angry and fired up
you did the right thing the
investigation needs to be done by the
police
but man i'm telling you this if that had
been my friend
a we would have done the same thing call
the police you got to
but b man i would have been at his house
i probably would have beat the cops
there
because i take the accountability part
of my friendship real real seriously
and here's the deal vice versa
man i would probably be more nervous to
face the cops in that situation i'm
facing my buddies in that situation the
cops cause there'd be no quarter
they would probably shoot me before the
police did
and so again
has your friend not called you hadn't
reached out to you
it's just not been talked about at all
he doesn't know that i
know basically
so it's just it's hush-hush
so he's having this trouble in his
marriage is he still married
uh yes
what's his what's his wife doing about
it
man i got all kinds of questions now man
this thing's just getting weirder and
weirder
what's she doing about it yeah it's a
bit of a train wreck
so initially she was upset with them and
left them
obviously but and so hey the guy who you
were the best men in their wedding
and he was the he's gonna be the best
man in your wedding god i hope he's
still not
he's gonna be the best man in your
wedding
he didn't call you when his wife left
him
uh he did uh and we talked
i hadn't known that he's had a an
addiction with
pornography before
and he had mentioned that as being part
of it
but at this point i had known but he
didn't
uh come out with me uh
with the the
um deeper part of it he didn't come out
to me with that
all right charlie brother i know you
called me to ask me what to do with your
friend
and i'm turning this around on you your
friends i mean if somebody's soliciting
miners for nude photos from them
that that's a class of person that we
don't even need to discuss any further
on this show
i think we all will be in agreement on
that and if you're listening to the show
and you're not in agreement on that like
no that's cool bro
don't ever listen to the show again just
find something else to listen to because
you're an idiot
but i think we're all in agreement on
that right
right so the problem here in this
situation charlie is you
and i'm telling you that because i love
you but if you've got a best friend on
planet earth
that you feel this uncomfortable about
calling them out on something this
big they're not your friend man
either that or you have some deep
character challenges that you're gonna
have to work through
because you owe it to yourself you owe
it to that
the kids he was getting involved with
you owe it to your
future partner you owe it to him
man if someone has entrusted you with
their friendship
that's both good and bad it's hard
conversations and good conversations
and i've been recipient of some hard
hard truths in my life from men who are
close to me
and women good good friends
and it has been ugly and painful and
hard in almost every single time
it's been a gift that i couldn't
calculate
how valuable that gift was
but what you need to do is call your
friend
and say man i haven't been honest with
you i've known about this for a long
time
i called the cops on you dude and here's
the thing
if it's not true if it didn't happen
then the cops aren't going to find
anything
and since 95 or whatever the crazy
number is of
people in this country look at
pornography the cops can roll their eyes
if he did they do an investigation then
he's going to get busted he should
okay it's that simple but you owe it to
your friend
who was the best man in your wedding and
who was so close to you you were going
to have him in your wedding
you owe it to him to call him and be
upfront with him
and to confront to hold accountable and
in that process man you're with him
right
you don't we don't abandon our friends
not like that
but we don't gloss over it and just be
like oh sweet dude cool bro
no man charlie you got to step up here
or
he's not your friend and you got to just
walk away and let that sucker ride
but man
we've got to have friends guys
and gals we gotta have friends and that
doesn't mean just people who surround us
with good things that make us
smell like flowers and roses but who
will tell us
hard hard truths about ourselves who
will
um show up at our front door when we
need help and it will show up at our
front door
to put a size 12 boot
interface right in my right my mouth
right my teeth
and man maybe i'm just a lucky guy man
that i've got friends that will do that
for me but charlie you need to be that
guy
if anybody out there has great close
friends
and they they're like i don't want to
get have that conflict have the conflict
man that's what you're supposed to do
all right i'm just going to go on thanks
for the call charlie hey here's the deal
have this conversation charlie and then
call me back because i want to know how
it goes
um it's probably not going to go well
but that's a good thing this kind of
conversation can't go well
but let me know how it goes all right
let's go to candace in fort collins
colorado candace what's going on how can
i help
hey dr daloy um so a few weeks ago
i found out about my husband's porn
addiction
um that he's been keeping a secret for
our entire relationship
how long have you all been together um
married for three together for six okay
um he has been addicted since he was
12. okay um and i just want to know
how to establish trust going forward
and how to help him overcome this
addiction
so one i'm sorry that you just
discovered this how did you figure it
out how did you discover it
um i actually had a dream about it and
i confronted him about my dream and he
was like what the heck
and came clean about everything
yeah because he realized oh god i'm
married to a sorcerer this is not going
to end well for me right
um if you had a dream and you just
thought well i think my husband's
got some addiction challenges and then
you just asked him about it and he's
like
oh busted i didn't believe the dream
like i thought it was just a random
dream but i was like hey i had this
dream
it's kind of weird and then he yeah
wow so how'd that how'd the conversation
go tell me about how that conversation
went
um he at first
kind of like
made it seem like it wasn't as much of a
big deal like
he was kind of denying it at first but
then he eventually
um just started i don't know
it's i i
let's see because he he was like asleep
and then he woke up and he was kind of
groggy and then he
he finally started telling me like
yeah this yeah i've been watching porn
like for a long time
and he made it sound like it was like
every like few months but
then he actually said it's more like
weekly
so um tell me what was going on in your
heart
were you just devastated did you kind of
know already or was it did it answer a
lot of questions for you was it weird
were you more annoyed that he's been
keeping secrets from you
what was what's going on in your in your
soul
like all of the above like at first i
was
completely shocked i had no idea
i thought we were like
the couple that never had to deal with
that type of thing
that was shock and hurt
but as he started telling me more and
more i also felt
empathy towards him because he's been
keeping it a secret for so long and
he doesn't want to be doing this yeah
and he doesn't know how to
get out of it you know yeah so
here's the the good news and the bad
news the bad news is you can't
make him do anything
he's gonna have to decide that he wants
to change whatever behavior it is
um anytime we i talk to folks about
addictive behaviors
um
i always want to make sure we're talking
about it at a 30 000 foot view
and so addiction is addiction is
addiction and some people
use pornography and sleep around some
people use heroin and some people work
90 hours a week
and some people are addicted to being
right they're addicted to power
and embossing on people around addiction
is addiction is addiction and the
chemicals
involved are very similar and for some
folks
pornography is not that big of a deal
for other folks it's devastating in
their soul
and so he who he is married to
which is you right y'all gonna have to
sit down and have an honest not groggy
conversation not a hem-holly
conversation
but a direct conversation about how this
particular behavior makes you feel
and you're going to have to have a
specific conversation about
what the violation feels like and you're
going to have to do some work on your
own to decide to
kind of divvy up here is it the secrets
that broke your heart
is it the fact that he's been struggling
with something for six years and he's
kept that from you
or is it the actual he is
looking at naked people and he is um
thinking about other people that are not
me
right and it's probably like you said
it's it's a mixture of all of that
what i'll tell you is it's been my
experience that the deepest pain
underneath all those layers is the
deception
and the fact that you weren't worthy
enough to be trusted with a hurt he had
especially for that long right that's
hard
um is that overcomeable for sure
1 000 million percent yes okay
um what you're gonna have to do is be
honest with him about
your feelings and even if it's not all
parsed out at the beginning if it's a
jumbled mess
still sit down and be honest with him
and you may have already done this if
you haven't
please take the time to write out how
you feel get all those feelings down so
that they're
you can see them laid out they're in an
order and then i want you to draw your
boundaries pretty firmly
here's what i won't accept in my house
here's what i won't tolerate in the
house
um and here's who i expect the man that
i'm married to be
and then he's gonna have to make some
decisions and um
this can be a challenging thing and this
can be a not challenging thing this
could be just some hard decisions he's
got to make and then y'all are going to
work together
and then this is just going to be a
story this is just going to be a
footnote in the history of your
relationship moving forward and so i
don't want to undermine it and i don't
want to over sensationalize it i want to
get right direct in the middle of it and
deal with it directly does that make
sense
yeah it does what i'll tell you is
tiptoeing around
holding him hostage with you right
um addiction at the end of the day is a
connection disorder right it is
people trying to fill voids
relational voids with stuff with things
with other chemical processes that are
cheap chemical substitutes for the
chemicals we get when we are connected
with other people
and so when folks use harsh
uh use they weaponize certain things man
it just makes things worse
and so all that to say is be vulnerable
with him
be clear with him set really firm
boundaries with him
um love him he's your husband
love him walk alongside him but you
can't do the work for him he's gonna
have to make some hard decisions
by the way here's what some hard
decisions might look like
that he doesn't have a computer in the
house that he's got to go through you
for the netflix login that
um he has there you know there's a
number of web filters that will
send you everything that he goes to and
looks at et cetera et cetera et cetera
that you've got unfettered access to his
phone it's going to depend on how
serious he is about taking care of
himself okay and
keeping your relationship in a good
healthy place
um and then you may as part of this
vulnerability conversation
he may talk to you about some things
that he struggled with you over the last
six or seven years and y'all will have
to
be able to hear that and heal your
relationship from the floor up right
and so this is a 360 degree conversation
moving forward but all you can control
is you
you can't do the hard work for him and
but i do want you to keep the light on
in this relationship
man because there's a lot of hope at the
end of this thing okay
okay so so you've known him for six
years
do you believe him that he wants to stay
married that he wants to
have a whole relationship a whole
connection with you that he wants to be
plugged in
and make this thing work i do
yeah he is committed to seeing a
counselor
and figuring out like how deep this goes
yeah so there's there's the spelunking
expeditions there's the seeing how deep
it goes and then there's the really
um there's the simple
behavior stuff right we need some
strategies pretty quick
right like if he was an alcoholic we
wouldn't have alcohol in the house and
you would commit to not drinking around
him and when friends came over you'd let
him know hey guys don't bring beer over
the house don't bring whiskey over the
house because
um because husband's getting clean right
or if he was
addicted to working too much or addicted
to being busy all the time
you'd set some pretty y'all two would
co-create some boundaries together
on when at six o'clock i'm coming home
no matter what and if i lose my job i
lose my job but i'm gonna start
learning how to invest in my family
learn how to be at home and so this is
similar to that there's some
deep stuff you got to get to the roots
and all that stuff but there's also some
just
behavioral issues that y'all can address
right away together
and if it helps to go to the therapist
with them go to counselor with them and
y'all learn some new strategies together
that would be awesome
that'd be good um do you want to stay
married to this dude
i do yeah are you sure committed
yes okay because i hear there's just
something there's a
i'm trying to think what it is there's a
sense of resignation in your voice it
may just because you're nervous because
you're on the radio but there's a sense
of resignation in your voice
um if he's in
and you're in i want you to be all fully
in
okay someone who's a true addict knows
when somebody's not being fully present
with them
and that's what you go chasing that full
presence okay
okay do you feel good about that
yeah i i do yeah okay good so tonight
uh maybe not tonight tonight i want you
to take time writing this letter
uh writing out here's all of my feelings
on this
and a couple again a couple of places to
start i've already mentioned this
is just the sexual ethic violation if
this violated
a commitment you all had with one
another man call that out
um if this you're hurt because he kept
he was hurting for six years and he kept
that a secret from you
man call that out if you are devastated
by the secrecy
and the deception and the lying call
that out
you sh all those all those things should
be right
um and if there's more to it than that
put everything out
in an orderly way let him know how you
feel not in a shameful way but in an
honest direct way that's you being
vulnerable
and hear him as he responds as he as he
um gives it back to you and i've got
high hopes for your relationship i want
you to let me know how that conversation
goes with him
um and again if both of y'all are all in
you all have a bright future together
candace um and we'll be thinking about
y'all
all right so um i don't
some people know that some don't we
shoot this show several weeks in advance
and so sometimes i'm behind you know
something big happens and i can't
address it until a few weeks later so
today is the day that um
our new president joe biden was
inaugurated the
he gave a speech today and by the time
this comes out he'll have been
in the off in office for a few weeks i
just want to uh
put this forward um i i have a uh
i love being a chameleon when it comes
to hey who does that guy vote for and
what is he
i i that's a part of the fun for me um
my wife and i don't talk about who we
vote for with one another and i'm a big
believer that you can't have a strong
position on one side of us
of a discussion unless you could win an
argument against yourself on the other
side
taking a one-sided position and just
going to war without knowing
and understanding and empathizing with
people on other sides of issues
i don't even like the language other
side because issues are so
circular man there's so much going on
all the time
i like people not knowing where i stand
on a lot of those things
but i will tell you this this i i feel
this in my bones
this is a moment for us
and this is one of those moments when
you get to decide we get to decide
who we're going to be and how we're
going to handle things moving forward
and so i want everyone to know that i'm
going to be a person
committed to kindness not resignation
not silence but to kindness and to
unity and to saying i'm sorry and just
saying hey i don't understand that will
you we help me out
um i thought the speech today was
extraordinary thought it was good
i thought it spoke to all sides to
everybody
everybody's concerns not everybody's
concerns there's all kind of concerns
all over the freaking place
but it spoke to a full degree of
humanity
and now we all have a decision to make
are we going to disagree with some
things that
biden does yep are we going to agree he
didn't go fur farther
far enough yep are we going to agree i
wouldn't yep yep and yep and yep
and at the end of the day i got to go
back to pumping gas
next to my neighbor i've got to see
james in the stinking hallway nobody
wants to see james
in the hallway who wants to see james in
the hallway we all have to right
not cool man not cool man
um but we're going to see one another
we're going to have to figure
this out so i want you to know i'm all
in i hope you will be all into
um let's put down the swords let's put
down the rhetoric let's put down the
devices and let's figure this out
we got a long way to go and i'm just
telling you i got a 10 year old and
a and a 5 year old and i'm not going to
give up on their behalf
and um we're going to love each other
and i think what joe had to say today
was just was extraordinary it was an
excellent way to kick it off and i'm all
in i'm all in on i hope he wins because
if he
if if he does well we all do well and if
we all do well
we're gonna pick ourselves up off the
pavement where we've been laying for the
last
little bit and we're gonna um see some
light at the end of some of these
tunnels so let's go do it together
i'm in hope you're in with me all right
let's take one more call
let's go to uh charlie in indianapolis
charlie what is going on how can i help
hey dr d how's it going we are we are
figuring it out every day
there's people out in the lobby just
eating cookies hanging out
yeah it's good to see that's good and
then it's just me and you here
going for it charlie so what's going on
how can i help um
so i'm kind of put myself back out in
the dating scene and i've been with this
guy for i don't know let's say a month
now hold on
so before that so you said you're going
back to the dating scene were you in a
long-term thing
um well it was five years ago that i was
in a relationship
and that relationship kind of ruined me
and so i just kind of took time to take
care of myself
wait hold on what do you mean it ruined
you
i don't like that language that makes me
like ah you're not ruined you're awesome
why would why did it ruin you um
i guess i it just didn't leave me in
in the best version of myself and i
didn't like who i was after i left
man you were being cryptic charlie help
me out so
what do you mean um well he he cheated
on me
and then um i was emotionally invested
and i was heartbroken when i found out
and so um yeah i went i was
depressed for a little while maybe like
i would say like two years or something
but then
i came out of it and now i think i'm
ready to be in the dating scene again i
think
i think um but i've been with this guy
for a month
and i just feel a little bit like i'm
like suffocating a little now
with him i think maybe because i've just
been so used to being alone and
independent and
doing things in my own time and so i'm
sort of just wondering how i can gently
let him know
that i'm feeling just a little bit
suffocated
yeah and charlie there's a lot here and
i don't even know that you know there's
a lot here
um
james how much time we got we have a
four or five hours we can sit down and
talk through this
probably not nope okay so
oh man okay let me ask you a few more
questions charlie
okay so five five years ago y'all broke
up or y'all were together for five years
and then you found some stuff out about
him he was cheating on you and you were
all in invested and it just rattled you
to your core
and you didn't like some things about
you i'm just gonna infer maybe you
made some you made some behavioral
decisions you did some things that
you're like man that's not stopped me or
you reacted in some ways it's just not
me
um and now you're coming out of it and
you're ready to get back into it and
you're back into it
and you're like oh this this is not the
dude is that where we're at
yeah i think so kind of so give me an
example of something when you say it
just wasn't me
what did you do that you look back and
go oh
geez louise that was not me um
but it was you but that's not me but it
was you but you know what i mean
yeah i think i think one
one major difference after that is
i just noticed that um i kept to myself
a lot more i'm usually a person that
like likes to go out and
interact with people and meet new people
and so
after that i was just home a lot um
sitting in the corner of a room
oh man okay yeah and yeah and that was
just pretty much it and my closest
friends and family
um they noticed that and they pulled me
out of it gracefully
and so i think i'm in a good spot now
and with this new guy
um i want to give the good parts of me
to him but then
i'm just a little bit afraid maybe that
because he's so good to me that
it's just too good to be i don't too
good to be true maybe
okay so that was gonna be my first
question is this dude just lane
no he's he's amazing actually he's
really good um
he he's vulnerable with his feelings
which is something that i was looking
for
um he he makes me a priority
which is not nothing i've ever had
before um
and he's just he's just overall good and
so i don't
i don't know if i'm actually feeling
suffocated or if i'm just
worried that i'm gonna become
emotionally invested again
and then yeah okay so that's now it's
much now i've got a more
uh a much clearer picture okay okay
so i'm gonna tell you a couple of things
about your heart
and your brain that is hopefully will
give you some peace
okay okay number one
you got hurt bad is that right yeah
it was pretty bad okay so i want you to
know that it's brave that you even say
that out loud good for you
okay you got you got roasted you got
burned
okay and that hurts and when we get hurt
then our brain remembers that pain
especially deep violations
of connected relationships to our
childhood trauma when parents abuse
their kids or parents neglect their kids
that trauma stays with us forever unless
we do some hard hard work
because our brain remembers i ain't ever
gonna hurt like that again
right and so if this is a guy how old
are you
i'm 25. okay so this dude you're with
for five years you had plans with him
huh
yeah i did you were you were
looking at furniture in your mind for
not even the first house but the second
house right yeah
naming kids and things like that okay so
that hurt bad
right and it wasn't just a breakup hurt
but it was a violation hurt
and your brain notched that and said
all right that's never happening again
because your brain's job is not to make
sure you are happy and that there
are snowflakes and rainbows everywhere
it's to make sure you're alive
right and so
every time from this point forward for a
season when you start getting close
and it recognizes oh crap she's falling
in love it's gonna sound the alarms
okay okay because it's assuming hey you
forgot what happened
last time genius we're not doing this
again right
so every time you feel that
that suffocation feeling that tightness
in your chest that
ah that it's too good to be true that
just
smile and understand that your brain's
just trying to take care of you
okay it's just trying to love you the
best way it knows how and our brains are
sometimes really incredible and
sometimes they're blunt instruments
okay okay and sometimes you may even
need to go
hey thank you for taking care of me i've
got it i appreciate you
okay here's the second thing when you
are
when people get cheated on especially in
a long-term relationship
there's the the obvious pain i lost this
relationship there's the pain of
betrayal
sometimes people often people stay
together and
they have to learn how to love again
they've got to learn how to trust again
and it look they have to build something
new what people
often don't talk about in when someone
gets cheated on when someone
betrays somebody else like this is that
you
lose trust in yourself
you lose trust in charlie's judgment
because you didn't see this coming
you were all in had you known had you
seen this coming you would have
protected yourself and you missed it
right that and i'm not saying this is
your fault i'm just saying here's the
narrative that goes in our minds
how could i have not seen that and then
you may even start
rewinding the history of your
relationship and you start realizing i
did know
i saw that i didn't want to see it i saw
that i saw him hide his phone i saw this
i saw that
and i i blocked it out of my mind i
didn't want to see it
and then you start beating yourself up
but there's this loss of trust in
yourself
right and you sound like someone who is
super lucky that
you not lucky you've worked hard to
cultivate awesome friends around you is
that right you got a good you got a good
squad that runs with you yes they always
tell me straight up what's wrong
oh that's so good man um yeah you're
that's a that's a gift
in it man nurture that nurture that
forever friends or
everything um but here's what you have
to do you have to learn to trust
yourself again
and you only can learn to do that by
practicing right by leaning into those
really uncomfortable moments and so
here's the hard truth i'm going to give
you ready
yeah i'm ready this guy may be
incredible
you may have had a disastrous
heartbreaking relationship and you may
be ready to get back on
on on the horse or back in the wagon i
don't know any non-west texas references
here back on the
on the harley i don't know what i don't
know what happens in indianapolis but
whatever
um but you may be ready to get back on
and then your first
the first the first rattle out of the
bag the first game he's the one
right you're 25 you found him and it's
gonna be it forever
or charlie he may cheat on you
he may suck and here's what i'm telling
you that i'm not telling that to be me
and i'm telling you this
all relationships a hundred percent of
them
are a risk
they're a risk they're scary and
that's what makes them hard and that's
what makes them so
incredibly important for us and so
you're gonna have to lean into that risk
you're gonna have to lean into that
unknown you're gonna have to let your
brain know hey
i know this could happen again i'm gonna
walk
i'm gonna take the lessons that i
learned last time i'm gonna be open and
vulnerable with this new guy
and he turns out he's a dweeb he's a
dork man then i'm out
right and listen to your body if you're
like dude you're suffocating me man quit
texting me weirdo
then tell him that right you can tell
him okay
if you start thinking this guy's
incredible
i'm not ready yet let him know that
and you don't have to be ready you know
whose timetable you're on
nobody's just yours okay
okay there's no rules to this deal other
than you
be honest and vulnerable and you be true
to yourself
and then what however you move forward
is however you move forward
okay you my new sister charlie are in
full
full control okay of the story of the
narrative
of the potential of getting hurt again
and
the potential of being loved and loved
and loved and loved
and love is a risk and it's hard and
it's scary and it's so so good
what do you think um
no crying on my show charlie just
kidding
i'm crying tears of um a good
confirmation
because i think i've i know i know all
that and it's just good to hear from
someone else
that that isn't in my circle that that
maybe i'm just not lying to myself or
fooling myself
because these people just want to please
me or who i
am but i appreciate that
hey listen i appreciate you for being
brave i appreciate you for being bold
and for listening to your body
and not ignoring your heart and also not
being afraid to push through when it
gets real scary
and listen you know who needs to hear
this
this guy yeah
does he know that that you were in a
five-year relationship and and that
guy cheated on you and things got messy
and you got your heart broken does he
know this
no he doesn't yeah so maybe maybe you'd
be vulnerable at some point let him know
okay i want you like you know what i
mean think of it this way if one time
you were
training for a marathon and you stepped
off the curb accidentally and broke your
ankle
and then you went through you just spent
a season not running because you got to
let your leg heal
and then you went to rehab and then you
started jogging around the block and
then you joined a runner's group
you'd probably let them know hey listen
i'm going to do the best i can with what
i've got i've got to get back in shape
this whole thing's new and i don't trust
my new leg yet
my rehabbed ankle yet i'm gonna have to
build some trust in it
and some people in that group are like
well forget you bro i'm taking off i'm
getting my super marathon time
but a big chunk of that group would be
like sweet you run with us
right okay and it's just learning to
step on that on that ankle
until you know it's strong you know it's
good and you've got good friends i can
tell on the phone you've got a
like a indianapolis sized heart i don't
even know how
big that is i was gonna say texas-sized
heart but i don't know you that well
but you have an indianapolis-sized heart
you're made of gold and
somebody's gonna be lucky to to have you
in their life
and it's okay to go slow okay
and i'll tell you this you have blessed
me today charlie um
i i appreciate you calling and being
vulnerable and
um trust your heart and trust your body
trust your friends and most importantly
trust
you all right so as we wrap up today's
show
man i was thumbing through some old uh i
have these awesome devices
that i listen to music on called cds you
should have seen
james's face when i asked him hey will
you burn this uh
this song onto an mp3 and burn it onto a
cd
and he looked at me like hey man can i
borrow your horse for the weekend
so i can ride to the marketplace uh i
still listen to cds i don't have one of
those fancy wires in my
truck cd player and my truck radio
whatever and i was going through my cds
over the weekend
and man i found this old song this is
one of the best songs
ever written of all time and i listened
to it on repeat over and over
look it up on spotify it's incredible by
the way we made a spotify playlist it's
the john dalony playlist
you can go to it it's official it's got
the songs from the show on it
some of them i've not put in there
because they weren't great but most of
them are all
in there this is one of the greatest
songs of all time
it's by a one of my favorite singer
songwriters his name is erin mccowan
and this is from her distillation record
back in 2000
and the name of the song is called fast
as i can and she writes
tonight woke i in a strange bed a
strange bedfellow strange
said to me oh you'll be all right you'll
be all right
and i said to it success i didn't
recognize you at first but then i said
to it success you don't look the way
i've dreamed of you the way i've dreamed
of you well not strange said success to
find me here tonight's not strange said
success
so what say you to a bargain you and i
success in life
what say you to a bargain you and i
success
and success it said to me forget about
the beds of middle america
you don't need the fat of the man why
don't you sleep with me tonight that's
all you've got to do to make it
and we'll die as fast as we can well i
said to success
i couldn't love you if i tried well i
said to it success
i couldn't love you if i've tried and
i've tried and i've tried and i've tried
something about success that lies
aaron something about success that lies
in a strange bed next to me this is
bit i love that song this has been the
dr john dolone's show
you